the bottom line is that the only reason
the killer was in America in the first
place was because we allowed his family
to come here that is a fact and it's a
fact we need to talk about we have a
dysfunctional immigration system which
does not permit us to know who we let
into our country and it does not permit
us to protect our citizens properly with
50 people dead and perhaps more
ultimately and dozens more wounded we
cannot afford to talk around issues
anymore we have to address these issues
head-on I called for a ban after San
Bernardino and was met with great school
and an anchor but now many years and i
have to say many years but many are
saying that i was right to do so and
although the pause is temporary we must
find out what is going on we have to do
it it will be lifted this band when and
as a nation we're in a position to
properly and perfectly screen these
people coming into our country they are
pouring in and we don't know what we're
doing when I'm elected I will suspend
immigration from areas of the world
where there is a proven history of
terrorism against the United States
Europe or our allies until we fully
understand how to end these threats we
cannot continue to allow thousands upon
thousands of people to pour into our
country many of whom have the same
thought process as this savage killer
many of the principles of radical Islam
are incompatible with Western values and
institutions
remember this radical Islam is
anti-woman anti-gay and anti-american
immigration is a privilege and we should
not let anyone into this country who
doesn't support our communities all of
our communities every single one of them
America has already admitted four times
more immigrants than any country on
Earth anybody in the world four times
more at least because we don't even know
who's coming in and we continue to admit
millions more with no real checks or
scrutiny